nothing on this scale had ever happened
before in the UK an emergency alert sent
to every smartphone from a pub in
Southwest London to the slightly bemused
in The Kelpies and Falkirk
up and down the country the alarm
sounded eleven thousand people in the
Vitality stadium in Bournemouth
even military bans at York Minster were
out trumpeting it was a great
disturbance in the UK as millions of
phones suddenly cried out and were
suddenly silenced after 10 seconds the
alert stopped and the test concluded
but some of those alerts arrived early
and some of them late what was your
reaction when that came through I
actually didn't get
um a notification so that's fine
I think it was it as it build I had
actually only seen it on Instagram in
terms of like people's work
[Applause]
the system is designed to be used only
to warn of life-threatening situations
such as flooding fire or a terrorist
attack and it can be targeted
geographically so the whole country
doesn't get an alert there are nearly 60
million smartphones in the country so
never before have so many people been
watching exactly the same thing in this
country at the same time it's more
attention than you get for a pandemic
briefing for a royal wedding for a World
Cup final the difference with those of
course is that you choose to watch them
in this case with this new system the
government instead demands our attention
critics have said the alerts themselves
could put people's safety at risk
including drivers who may become
distracted and domestic violence victims
who keep a secret phone but others say
similar technology has long been used in
other countries and that it will help
Public Safety
vetted to be safe than sorry in these
situations so I know there are
Libertarians out there who don't want
this to happen uh you know they're going
to turn it all off and all the rest of
it but they might think twice when when
they wake up and you know the bottom of
their beds burning in a wildfire or the
waters seep you know into the into the
Boston rooms or something that kind of
scenario
the government said it was aware that a
very small proportion of people did not
receive any alert and they would work
with mobile operators to understand why
for a Sunday afternoon it was an
interruption on a grand scale normal
service though quickly resumed Tom
Cheshire Sky News Twitter Southwest
London